nerds thousands of them make an annual
pilgrimage to Reykjavik to celebrate EVE
Online a massive multiplayer online game
that takes place in outer space for
three days the gamers come together
dress up like their favorite characters
shop from an endless supply of swag
we should buy one of these and get a
sneak peek of what's on the horizon
there's also a massive live tournament
to decide who will become one of the
main rulers of the EVE universe where we
shall coronate our new leader and the
losers shall ritually sacrifice
themselves it's not going to last much
longer trading global blow here in the
final
and goes down
lock the halls here and you'll quickly
find yourself face-to-face with a wide
variety of geek species how many hours
would you play a day I'm logged in to
Eve probably six hours a day seven days
a week if I don't have other plans we're
logging in at least two or three times a
week and joining fleas and killing
people
it never stops and if you miss a day
then you're gonna have to make it up the
next day some people are the nicest
people you've ever met a rootless psych
thugs and bandits
at its most basic level EVE Online is a
war game set in space people build their
characters from scratch
hop in ships like this band together by
the thousands to form armies and fight
battles that can take months even years
from the outset it's been a game where
all of the players inhabit a single
universe and they collectively decide
how the game should be played
this makes Eve a neverending story
a spectacular communal experience so all
400,000 some odd people who play this
game we all playing together you get to
know the same people and there we have
space celebrities we have space
politicians and people know who they are
if you're a hero or villain in EVE half
a million people know your name know
your reputation and will either try to
take you down or follow you you know as
a result of that our chain of command
often goes the way that I believe most
do you have pac-10 works as a mechanic
by day when he logs on he becomes a
fleet commander with hundreds of
obedient soldiers ready to follow his
orders I have personally led little over
700 some people have led thousands do
you feel like you have two lives I don't
feel like I had two lives I feel like I
have one life that is very complicated I
try not to separate what I do and Eve
from the reality because it has an
impact and at the same time I try not to
let Eve become so real that I give up
things and you know my regular day job
and my life and seeing my real world
friends for a game it's easy to write
off Eve players as obsessive online
gaming nerds really easy but that would
do to service to the depth of the game
and the fan fest experience
you